- Today we're gonna cover the topic
of Amazon managing capacity,
EC2 capacity, and availability,
and the trade-offs that come with it.
With me, I got Brian Phillippi.
Brian, would you like
to introduce yourself?
- Sure.
Hi everyone. My name's Brian Phillippi.
I'm a Principal Product Manager at an EC2.
I've been with AWS for
about eight years now.
Fun fact about me.
Today is Cyber Monday, so
don't forget to, you know,
go to Amazon and check out the deals.
But I used to be, when
I first started at AWS,
I used to plan capacity for Cyber Monday.
So I live, eat, sleep
and breathe capacity.
So I'm really excited to be here with you.
- And in my case, I'm
Carlos Manzanedo Rueda.
I'm the lech lead for Compute.
I'm an SA.
I help organizations to
find those trade-offs,
and especially on optimization
and everything that
come with the trade-off
for that optimization,
and obviously capacity and availability,
also together with price
performance and cost
is among top of those things.
Before we start with the agenda,
I would like to cover a couple of things.
First one, please show
hands or raise your hands
if you are part of the
financial operation or FinOps
or have been doing FinOps.
Okay, I was expecting that.
How many of you are coming from
a platform engineering team
or basically manage capacity
as part of either an
organization or a platform team?
Perfect.
So you see, again part of the
audience with you on that one.
And finally, who of you
are application owners
or perhaps developers
and are basically looking at things
as availability and so on?
Awesome.
So you see that more or less
that covers pretty well the audience.
I probably left a few personas,
but I'm sure that you have
to balance those trade-offs
between those things.
And this is what this
talk is gonna be about.
We're gonna cover first
what is the challenge,
and again, with the framing
that we have set up,
you more or less know
what's gonna be about.
We're gonna cover what
are the usage models,
EC2 usage models that will help us
to define for different type of workloads,
what is best for your application,
starting with on-demand,
on-demand capacity reservation,
capacity blocks, spot instances.
And finally, we're gonna
introduce a few things
that have been released
in the last two months
or even in the last week
that are perhaps a bit new.
This is a 300 level session
so there's expected some
level of hands-on proficiency
on the topics that we're gonna cover.
For those of you that
perhaps there's new things
that we're covering,
this is gonna give you the
pointers to do the homework
and learn how you can apply
as part of basically your
day-to-day activities
on that capacity planning,
availability and so on.
We will end with some key takeaways.
And let's start with that challenge first.
We were talking about these trade-offs
and how we apply those trade-offs.
I'm sure that we have heard that,
hey, cloud and capacity infinite.
And we know that there's a reality
and that reality is those physical limits
of how we manage that capacity internally,
which is what we'll cover over here.
And there's a trade-off
that comes with that,
that comes with how much
capacity is available
and therefore what's
gonna be the pricing model
and what's gonna be the
low prices that we can get
with those, how we can
maximize that efficiency.
Just to give you an example,
just to give you an example of that.
You probably have heard
within that balance of Spot instances.
So this is a spark capacity
that we got in our data centers,
availability zones and regions.
And we put those spark capacity
at your use for a step
discount of up to 90%.
But the trade-off
is that those instances
can be interrupted.
So there's a trade-off with
that availability, as you see.
We're gonna be exploring
all those different options
that you got with the
different usage models
so you can understand what
that level of capacity
versus availability
versus utilization goes.
Let's deep dive first
on on-demand instances.
Probably this is the usage model
that you are more familiar with.
On-demand instances are basically key
for your elasticity,
just to get that capacity when you need it
at the point that you need it.
So it simplifies a bit with
the pay-as-you-go model,
when do you need that capacity
and what are you gonna get it.
We got more than a thousand
instance at this point in time.
My recommendation is go and
pick the latest generation
of those instances.
Typically, they will come with
the best price performance
so that way you basically
get selection of instances
that is easier to manage.
And we offer those instances
in more than 120 availability
zones and 38 regions.
We also offer them on local zones
so you can manage also that
capacity and availability
in places where latency
is key for your customers.
Now, the way that we
use on-demand instances
is typically on stateful workloads
that have that scaling
patterns, so cyclical patterns.
Or perhaps you have some time of capacity
that you needed like spurious
or temporary short-term workloads
that you need that capacity.
And for those times where
you are not ready to commit
for a longer term like saving plans
and you like to basically testing
and wait until fingers scale
so you are ready to that commitment,
it's important to understand
how those capacity pools
for on-demand work.
At some point,
when you are selecting a
particular instance type,
that pool can go down
and you may suffer from
insufficient capacity error.
We on the back,
do lots of things to make
sure that doesn't happen
and we present to you that elasticity
that we were talking about.
Behind the scene, we are
definitely doing that forecasting
to get the capacity up front.
We are doing also placement in the regions
where that capacity is needed
and removing the any
bottleneck to rack and stack
as fast as we can.
Behind the scenes, we're doing
things like pool balancing.
For example, where you have an excess
or we have an excess
of 16x large instances
for a particular type of instance.
If at some point there's a need for 4XL
we will split those instances
and we'll create four out
of those 4XL instances.
We'll be creating that supply and demand.
But still, there's gonna
be kind of at some point
if you select only just one instance type
a point where a particular
pool may dry out.
Just to give an intuition
of that capacity,
we just released M8i, so the
new Intel software, Rapid,
about two months ago.
About month ago, we released also the M8a,
the Turin version.
I would recommend you just
taking a look at those.
As you may expect,
even if we are racking and
stacking as fast as we can,
these are new instances
so there's gonna be
less capacity of those.
Even if those are just
preferred instances,
you need to take into consideration
that capacity availability factor
that we were just mentioning.
One way of doing that is being flexible.
And we are at Vegas so let's
use the analogy of a buffet.
You may want to go for the ravioli
and perhaps at that point in the buffet
there's not gonna be ravioli so, so bad.
I'm sure that if you are flexible
and you like all the pastas,
you are gonna be still
getting the right meal.
And not only that, if you
are flexible with the rest
of the food, you'll get even
a better meal out of it.
So then that concept of flexibility
that improves how you tap on
different pools of capacity,
you can expand that to
protect yourself effectively
when you're using on-demand instances
and still go to your preferred instance,
but know that you can
always protect yourself
with ICE if you are a bit flexible.
The way that you apply that flexibility
is either using different
instance families
or perhaps a different CPU manufacturer
in x86 Intel AMD,
different generations or different sizes.
I understand that a few of you
for especially large
organizations may do some level
of qualification of instances
just to verify that those instances
match the service level
objectives that you need.
When you have deterministic
workloads need,
the deterministic performance need,
this make a lot of sense.
I would like you to
challenge those conceptions
and think that in most of the cases,
even when you qualify, what you are after
is not at the deterministic
level of performance.
You are after a baseline.
And after that baseline,
you can use other instances.
For example, if your baseline gets met
with a generation seven instance,
probably generation eight is
gonna be still equally valid.
Okay?
So you can think about
those levels of flexibility
that we just mentioned.
Applying that flexibility
is easier than you think.
We have embedded all the
ways to do the heavy lifting
both on EC2 fleet and auto scaling groups.
And those integrates with
the rest of our service.
For example, behind Karpenter,
you're gonna find EC2
fleet making that selection
and allowing you through the note pools
to create that exact
elasticity and flexibility
through multiple instance.
And the same thing goes
for auto scaling groups
that integrate with AWS
batch, with ECS and so on.
Now, the way that use it, super simple,
you will define or create a set
of fleet auto-scaling group,
apply that flexibility that you're after
and effectively let that
fleet auto-scaling group
manage the instance lifecycle for you.
We introduced about two
and a half years ago,
three years ago,
the concept of attribute-based
instant selection.
This is a way that allows you
to define what is your flexibility
and your instant selection
through properties or attributes.
For example, you can say,
hey, I would like any type of instance
that offers me this many CPUs,
there's much memory on a latest generation
or generation six on what and
on the storage type of EVS.
And that will define the type of instances
that create that
flexibility group for you.
You can still define perfectly,
that's perfectly fine to define
the instances manually too.
When you define those instances,
for example, just to give you a pattern
that you can use for on-demand instance
to protect yourself,
you can start defining
with a prioritized allocation strategy,
a group of instances and
you will list them in order.
You will start saying, hey,
this is my preferred instance,
but if I cannot get that instance,
I'm okay to get my second
preference and my third preference
and my fourth preference.
The main idea is that you
are protecting yourself
and making sure that auto scaling group,
if you cannot find your
preferred instance,
it will ya onto the next one
so you'll not suffer those ICEs, right?
So this is a pattern that
I would recommend using.
Allocation strategies can also be used
in the case of Spot, for example,
as capacity optimize allocation strategies
that will pick instances
from the deepest spools
so they will avoid
frequency of termination
or an increased frequency of termination.
And if you are price sensitive,
we have allegation strategies also
that are driven by the price optimized.
So you'll list all the instances
and we'll pick the ones
that are optimizing
for price for you.
As an example of this
attribute-based selection
and how you apply it,
you got in this case,
hey, I want eight CPUs,
eight kilobytes of RAM of
type Graviton and EBS storage.
And that automatically will
create that flexibility group
that includes m8g.2xlarges up to,
as you see on the left corner down, c7gn.
So these are network specialized instance,
and we'll pick up from those.
So it's easier effectively
to plug that model.
So if you want that deterministic
level of performance
or specific instance types,
we're gonna move to on-demand
capacity reservations.
Brian.
- Thank you.
So like Carlos mentioned,
if you really need to optimize
for a specific instance type
and you need to have the capacity there,
you can use a capacity reservation,
which is kind of on the
other end of the spectrum of,
you know, cost and availability,
capacity reservations.
You essentially hold or
you pay for the capacity
the entire time you hold the reservation.
So let's talk a little bit
about what capacity reservations are.
So kind of the acronym
for capacity reservations
are on-demand capacity reservations,
or you might hear me call 'em ODCRs.
And essentially with these
you're actually reserving
a specific instance type
and availability zone combination.
So if we look kind of
at the capacity
availability hierarchy here,
we have on-demand.
And on-demand I would say is world class
in terms of the availability
that we can give to you
with all the different
number of pools that we have.
However, as Carlos mentioned,
you can actually go up in
terms of your availability
by accessing multiple
pools, by being flexible.
And then finally if you really,
really need to have that
capacity assurance there,
that's when you would use
the capacity reservation.
And the way we give you assurance
is we are actually setting
aside that capacity for you,
but because we're setting
aside the capacity for you,
we're not letting anyone else use it
or run instances on it,
and so we charge the entire
time you hold the reservation.
If you're running an instance
within the reservation,
no additional cost at all.
It just looks like a running instance
in your cost and usage report.
But if you're not running an instance,
that's when you'd be charged
for an unused reservation,
which charges basically the same thing
as a running instance.
But the good thing about
capacity reservations
versus especially if any
of you have been with AWS
for a long time, things like zonal RIs,
with capacity reservation,
there's no commitment period.
You can cancel it at any time you want to.
There's no one or three
year commitment period,
I should say.
So when should we use an ODCR?
First is if you don't have flexibility.
And that picture is a picture
of me getting up this morning.
But when you don't have flexibility,
if you're, you know, you're at the buffet
like Carlos mentioned, and
you really need ravioli,
you know at 6:00 PM on a Friday
night in North Las Vegas,
that's when you would wanna,
you know, call and make a
reservation to make sure
that you're able to get your food.
And that's same thing
with capacity reservation.
If you really need a
specific instance type
at a specific time of day and
a specific availability zone,
you probably need to use
a capacity reservation.
The other time that we recommend
using capacity reservations
is this, if your workload
is just so critical
that you absolutely need to have,
you need to be able to spin up instances
or bad things happen,
then we also would recommend
using a capacity reservation.
So there's kind of two different ways
you can create the capacity reservation.
You can create it on-demand,
which means creating it
based on what capacity
we have in the pool.
So when you create it on-demand,
we'll take capacity and
set it aside for you.
Or you can actually create
it in a future date.
So for on-demand,
we often see customers
creating the on-demand portion
of the reservations
if they have a workload
that takes a while to scale.
So if I have a workload that it takes me,
you know, I need to provision
single instance at a time
or a couple instances at a time
to be able to get up to my scale,
it can be really frustrating to get 90%
through my deployment and
then run out of capacity.
So with a capacity reservation
you can actually get a synchronous call
to say is the capacity there,
it basically says yes or
no, is the capacity there?
And if it is there, it creates
the reservation for you
so that you can just
spin up those instances
at your leisure and know that
that it's gonna be successful.
The other time that we see customers
using the on-demand version
of capacity reservations
is when they have
already running instances
and they wanna cover
those running instances
with a reservation.
Like I mentioned, there's no extra cost
for covering a running
instance with a reservation.
But if you need to do
maintenance or bounce your fleet,
you'll be able to to do so
and make sure you can
get that capacity back
when you do the reservation.
So the other type we have
is future data capacity reservation.
And there are a few different use cases
for future capacity reservation.
One of them would be like
a peak event like Q4 peak,
like we're having right now
with Cyber Monday and Black Friday,
making sure that we have
capacity for a big event.
Another would be if you're
performing some big migration
and you wanna switch
to a new instance type,
a future data capacity
reservation can help you do that.
And then finally,
if you're increasing your
baseline, stair stepping it up,
a future capacity
reservation also can help.
And the way that it works is,
it's just kinda like
you're placing an order,
like we talked about, you're
calling the restaurant.
So you request for a capacity reservation
for the date that you need it.
So it could be anywhere
between five and 120 days
in advance of what you need.
And then you specify how
long you are planning
on holding the capacity,
typically because we might be racking
and stacking new servers for you
or setting the servers aside,
we ask for like 14 days of
usage after the reservation,
but you'll get an answer
or you'll get a reservation
created right then and there
and it'll be in an assessing state.
And then within about
five days we'll come back
and put that in a schedule state for you
and then you just need
to wait for the capacity
to become available and you
can launch your instances.
All right, so we've talked a lot about,
you know, what ODCRs are,
how to use, or how to get
them, what they're for.
So now let's talk a little
bit about how we use them.
So with an ODCR we kind of,
it kind of works on this
principle of matching.
So your instance needs
to match your reservation
and then the two will marry up
and you'll be able to launch
your instances with it.
So there's four kind of primary things
that you'll need to match
with your instance launch
and your reservation.
So first is instance type, whether it's,
you know, c6i.xlarge or m7i.xlarge,
whatever the instance type that you need,
the instance that you're launching needs
to match the reservation.
We also have availability zone
platform or operating system.
And then finally, tenancy.
Tenancy is whether it's
single or shared tenancy.
Most of our customers just
use the shared tenancy.
Now optionally, if you are
using a capacity reservation
with a cluster placement group
also aligned with it,
you'll need to match that
placement group ID with your ODCR.
Basically, cluster placement groups,
they help with things like
high performance compute.
Makes it so we put all of the instances
in a really close
co-location with each other
so that you have really fast latency
between the instance types.
Now, finally, you have to think
about instance eligibility.
Now, I would say for probably
80, 90% of use cases,
your instance eligibility
is just gonna be kind of the default
or open instance eligibility.
And what that does, it kind
of acts like a public pool
of capacity that anybody can tap into
the default when you're launch an instance
and the default when you
create a capacity reservation
is always gonna be open.
And so it always just kind of
works and works like magic.
However, if you have like
a multi-tenant account
where you are trying to protect capacity
from somebody else in your
account from using it,
you would wanna use targeted.
And targeted basically means
when you launch an instance you have
to specify either the reservation ID
or a resource group that
the reservation is in
and then that way you can kind of protect
and create a private pool of capacity
versus that public pool that the openness.
But typically it's multi-tenant accounts
that are using the targeted.
All right, so going to kind
of back to what Carlos said,
you know, if you
architect for flexibility,
you still may want to
use capacity reservations
from time to time,
especially if you have
spare capacity reservations
that aren't being used
but you wanna save them
for another time.
So with an auto-scaling group,
you know, how do we do that?
How do we make sure that
when the auto scaling group
picks the reservation,
say it wants to pick m8g.2xlarge,
that top left there,
but I have an m7g.2xlarge,
how do I make sure that
the auto scaling group
is marrying up with my
capacity reservation?
And so last year we
launched something called
ASG capacity reservation preference.
And with this, you can
actually set that preference
so that you get better utilization
of your capacity reservations.
So you can either use
capacity reservations only,
which basically means if you
have a capacity reservation
that matches something within
your auto-scaling group,
it will launch the instance
and it'll launch it using
the capacity reservation.
But if you don't have a
matching capacity reservation,
it will not launch an instance
and you'll get an error.
You can also use capacity
reservation first,
which is kind of similar,
but instead of when you don't
have a capacity reservation,
it'll actually try to use on demand.
So it'll first try to look
for a capacity reservation to use.
If it doesn't have one, then
it will fall back to on-demand
and go back kind of through that list
that Carlos was talking about where,
you know, try to find the most
highest priority instance.
So really what this does is it
helps you improve efficiency,
'cause that's, if you
wanna talk about cost
and availability, the way to save costs
when using a capacity reservation
would be to use it fully
and get the most bang for your
buck out of that reservation.
So let's talk a little bit
more about how we can do that.
First, one of the best ways
that you can get better utilization
out of your capacity
reservations is through sharing.
So imagine, you know, you're
a high priority workload
that only runs during the day
and maybe has a small baseline at night,
but in the middle of the night
there's not a lot of usage.
So in order to kind of fill in those gaps,
you can actually share
the capacity reservation
with other lower priority
workloads that can be interrupted.
And that's a really great way
that we see for our customers
to increase the utilization,
especially if they have spiky workloads
that need that capacity assurance.
So when you share reservation,
you can actually share across accounts,
you can share across organizations.
So you can share, you know,
one to many if you'd like.
Or you could even share
outside of your organization
with another account, if you want.
And the way that you do that
is you use Resource Access Manager or RAM
to set up the share.
Now by default, if I own the reservation,
so say I'm owning the reservation
and I share with Carlos over here,
if Carlos does not use the capacity,
then I as the reservation
owner will be charged for it.
So if he does use the capacity,
he's just charged for
whatever usage is happening.
And I don't get charged
anything for a used reservation.
However, say I am a central team
and I want the ability to kind
of control the reservation
and modify the reservation,
but I want Carlos to pay for it,
you know, so one way that you can kind of,
what what we launched last year
was the ability to
assign billing ownership.
So now I can assign billing
ownership to Carlos,
'cause Carlos is the one that came
and told me he wanted capacity.
I, as a central team can manage it,
but I can give it to Carlos
and make Carlos pay for any of the unused
because he was the one that asked for it.
And then just as a side note,
we just launched,
this year, we launched
the ability to share,
if you have a cluster
placement group ODCR,
you're able to share those as well.
So in the past,
reclaiming that capacity took
a little bit of manual work.
So if we're talking about like
the high priority workload,
if I'm that high priority workload
in the middle of the night and I realize,
oh, I need that capacity back,
you know, in the past what I'd have to do
is get on the phone or page in the on-call
for the low priority workload.
On-call gets up,
I've been an on call,
I'm sure many of you have been on-call
and you have to get up in the
middle of the night and log in
and it can take a lot of time
and manual effort to go
in and take the action
to kind of terminate
those running instances
so that the high priority workload
can get the capacity back.
And so that's what it used to be.
But so now when they
need the capacity back,
they can interrupt it with
a two minute notification
and then, you know, we
do all the automation,
we interrupt the instances,
we give it back to the right reservation
and then you're able to
launch your instances.
So I kind of like to set it up
like a, outline it like this.
So the ODCR is almost like
the parent reservation
and the interruptible ODCR is
like the child reservation.
There's a connection between the two.
I also like the parent-child relationship
because I have four kids
and my kids are always interrupting me.
But you can then share that
just that interruptible
capacity reservation
using the RAM share to your organization
and then take it back when you need it.
Now, just one quick note on
this is there's producers
and consumers with capacity reservations.
So the producer's obviously
the high priority workload,
but the consumer or the
low priority workload
needs to make sure,
we need to make sure that they know
what they're getting themselves into
because they could have
their instances interrupted.
So in order to launch into it,
the low priority workload
first needs to target
that capacity reservation
like we talked about.
But then they also need
to set the market type
to interruptable capacity reservation
in order to kind of tell us
that they're okay being interrupted.
But you can set this in a launch template
and kind of set it and
forget it and it all works.
And then just launch your
instances and then wait
or listen for that interruption notice.
And once it comes you
just save your progress
and you shut down,
shut down gracefully.
So finally, you know,
we've talked a little bit
about these two models,
the on-demand and on-demand
capacity reservations.
There is a way you can
actually tune the costs
of these capacity, tune your
costs and lower your costs.
And that's through something
called a savings plan.
And with a savings plan,
what you're really doing
is you're committing
to use some sort of capacity
for a certain amount of time,
it's basically an hourly commitment,
for at least one or three years.
With that hourly commitment,
you get a discount on the usage
that fits into that commitment.
So with, you know,
our top three-year instance savings plans,
you can get up to 72% off.
Now there are two different
flavors of savings plans.
So there's compute savings plans
and instance savings plans.
I would say the compute
savings plans are kind
of the ultimate in flexibility.
So if you need, say you
wanted to run a workload
and have it be eight hours in Americas
and then eight hours in Europe
and then eight hours in Asia,
you could use a compute savings plan
which allows you to get
a discount on any usage,
any instance type in any region
to kind of get that discount
and save save on your costs.
That gets you up to 66%
off of the on-demand price.
Or if you're, you know,
less flexible and you
wanna have a certain,
you wanna get a bigger discount but,
you know, stay within a region
or within an instance family,
you could use the instant savings plans.
So with that, I'm gonna
turn it back over to Carlos
to talk a little bit more
about a couple different usage models.
- So let's keep going
with the usage models
and different trade-offs.
We cover basically
deterministic performance
and on-demand capacity
reservation and on-demand.
There's one particular one
which is capacity blocks for ML
that target GPU instances
or accelerated compute
instance including training.
These are the instance
that probably first thing,
they're in high demand,
and being high demand,
as you would expect,
there will be in some cases,
a higher level of scarcity.
Second part is that that
harder to be flexible on,
especially for training.
There's lots of improvements
that are going on
on how you manage that
kind of flexibility.
As in if you check for training
or libraries or frameworks,
you'll find things like QT tile
or yaks or plenty of things
that are compiled,
time will try to basically
make the most of some DSL,
some domain specific language or language
and try to make sure that it compiles
to a specific target platform.
But the reality is that there's
a huge level of performance
that you can get out of GUPs.
And the level of performance
comes from maximizing
and getting the low level things right.
So in the case of GPUs like Nvidia,
quite a lot of these
training is done using CUDA
and maximizing and squeezing
down the bottlenecks
to get the right price performance,
which makes the whole
thing much more difficult
to get that flexibility across instances.
These instances are also expensive,
which means that getting
into a saving plans
might not be the right way to go
without doing any experimentation.
Capacity blocks is the construct
that help get that kind of
block for reserve capacity
from one to 26 weeks.
So that's half a year.
We extended that quite recently.
And for that duration of time.
When we apply that capacity block,
when we request a capacity block,
if we get that capacity block
and on-demand capacity reservation,
a reservation we'll put on top of it.
So if at some point,
for example, we are not
using that capacity blocks
with our own account, we
can use those techniques
that you just learned
from Brian to hand over
to other parts of your organization
and make the most of those.
When do we use capacity blocks?
As you would expect.
Training, if you know that
there's gonna be a big exercise
with training coming,
that's the right place to
think about capacity blocks.
Make sure that you have that
availability and that capacity.
If you have also a campaign,
a seasonal campaign
and that thing is coming,
no product launches and
stuff like that, same thing.
And obviously for some
level of experimentation
you want to have that capacity
over that experimentation
without doing that saving
plan's commitment over time.
So those are the places
where you think about capacity blocks.
You can get up to 64 instances
from one to 64 instances
when you multiply that in GPU,
that's 512 p6-200 GPUs, for example,
which gives for the moment
that you put that together
with a placement group,
cluster placement group,
to get all the bandwidth that you need,
gives for a really big
cluster for training.
Makes sense?
And obviously most of
these go on Linux systems,
any of the Linux systems.
The same concept of capacity blocks
for ML applies also to SageMaker.
So SageMaker training
plant is the equivalent of,
it has some differences in the way
that you can even apply
30 minute in advance.
And if that capacity is there,
it will come directly to you.
But it's used for pretty
much the same aspects.
It will plug and integrate
within SageMaker within HyperPod.
You can ask for ultra
cluster service as well.
So you can get also those p6-200s
that we were talking about.
And that experience will be both exposed
through the dashboard and through an API.
So you can get access to any of those.
You can as you would expect,
use it for predictable access
to accelerated compute,
as we were saying, including
Trainium 1 and Trainium 2.
And primarily to make sure
that you have all that capacity
and in the place where you
have the data, as I was saying,
most of these workloads are less flexible
that general workloads because of,
first, the reasons of compiling
to the target architecture,
but also the number,
how much data you need to
process those training models.
Right.
Let's move to the other
side of the spectrum.
You probably by now are acquainted
with what the Spot instances are.
I already mentioned in the
first part of the session.
These are spare capacity that
we got in our data centers.
They are sold with a step
discount of up to 90%.
Typically 60, 70% is what you'll find.
You can, coming in this part,
people forget that we have also,
if you can run opportunistic
workloads on GPUs,
you can also access
GPUs on Spot instances.
Now, the question is where
to find them obviously.
If you haven't heard about
the Spot placement score,
we'll talk about that in a second.
But let's cover the basic
four Spot instances,
which are mostly used with
CMs and R type of instances.
So yes, kind of regular type of instances.
The key for those usage is two things,
managing that too many termination notice.
So have some level of fault tolerance.
And second, the key thing
will be being flexible.
Being flexible across
many different dimensions.
You can use dimensions
of the instant sizes,
generations, types.
Or you can be flexible also
on time shiftable workloads.
So you can basically, typically
there's more capacity,
spare capacity overnight.
So you can basically move
some of the batch workloads
to overnight to find the
capacity at the scale
that you need at those lower prices.
If you are flexible towards region,
you can also move that
regional availability
or find that regional availability
using a Spot placement score.
So let's cover the aspect
of fault tolerance first.
We were talking about those interruptions.
We have still that two
minute interruption notice
which we are extending to
up to 30 minutes for GPUs.
We also are providing something
that is called a balancing recommendation,
which is effectively a notification
that we give in the worst
cases, two minutes in advance,
like the Spot termination.
But typically we tend to give
it 10, 15 minutes in advance,
telling you that that
instance is gonna put
at risk of termination.
And in fact we embed the
replacement of that instance
with some other instance
that looks similar
in auto-scaling groups
or in Karpenter as well.
You can even use fault injection service
to create a termination,
deliver a termination from your site
as part of your testing
model so you can verify
that your application
actually is fault tolerant
towards these terminations.
Verify how it works,
and even build it as part of
your continuous integration.
So I was saying, the key
thing is flexibility.
And aside from flexibility,
is that finding out which
dimension of flexibility
might be key for you.
I don't know how many of you have heard
about the Spot placement score.
We released it about two years,
two years and a half ago.
Spot placement score is an API
and it's in the dashboard as well.
You can select a diversified configuration
similar with the attribute-based
instance selection
that we were just sawing before.
You can also set up a target capacity.
For example, I would like
out of that attribute-based
instance selection example
that I use, 10,000 instance
or 50,000 instances.
It will give you a score from zero to 10.
Be in nine, you're
gonna find that capacity
and you're gonna get low
level of terminations
or at least the opposite.
You're probably not
gonna find that capacity
and the frequency of termination
is gonna be quite bad.
And it's gonna give you
effectively a number
for the different regions
that you are trying to get access to
or the different availability zone.
So if you have something
like a Spark workload
that is very chatty and you are trying
to avoid that inter
availability zone charges,
it can tell you which is
the right availability zone
for your analytic workloads, okay?
You can always do that manual selection
that we were talking about.
So we've been covering all
the different usage models
and now even how to put them at the scale.
The reality is that most
of our customers are gonna
have a mix of those models.
We just released something
that I'm super proud
of Brian's team on everything that they do
on how we can bring and put
all of those things together.
Brian, would you like to?
- Sure, thank you.
So like Carlos mentioned,
we see all these different
usage models being used
throughout organizations.
And there are different reasons
that we've gone over
why you would want to use
those different usage models.
And at a small scale it's pretty easy
to manage the capacity.
If you're just looking at a single region
or a single account, it's not too bad,
you can use the the console
to see exactly what's going on.
However, if you're in a large organization
trying to manage capacity
across the entire organization,
you're having to deal with
thousands of instance types,
potentially thousands of accounts
that you have to manage,
hundreds of availability zone,
dozens of regions
and a mixture of all of
these different usage models.
Now, AWS has a lot of different tools
that kind of could help with this
like cost and usage report,
describe APIs or even CloudWatch.
However, what we found when
talking to our customers
is that they had to kind of
keep going back and forth
between all of these different tools
to kind of figure out what's going on.
It could take 'em even hours
to kind of get a good picture
of what their capacity looks like
in order to be able to manage it.
So back in October,
we actually launched and released
something called EC2 Capacity Manager,
which kind of helps bring
all of those tools together
into a single uniform view.
So the idea is now you can see
all of your on-demand usage,
your ODCR usage, capacity block usage,
and even Spot data across
all of your regions
and across all of your
AWS accounts in one place,
and it's absolutely free.
So we're really excited about this
because we think it's gonna help you
to get a better picture,
to be more efficient and to be able
to manage your capacity more effectively.
So let's jump into a
little bit of a demo here.
So this is the kind of the
Capacity Manager dashboard.
And the idea with Capacity Manager
is to always start at a really high level,
kind of the 10,000 or 50,000 foot view,
and then give you the tools
to kind drill into your data.
So up top we have the dashboard
and then all of those
other tabs are tabs for you
to dive into your usage,
to dive into your
reservations or your Spot.
You can also set your date filters.
So you can set up the date filters
up to a few hours ago all
the way to 90 days ago.
And you can have granularity of a,
daily granularity if you
kind of wanna see trends.
Or if you really wanna get into the weeds,
you can see hourly granularity.
Now within the dashboard
we have an overview section
and you'll be able to see really quickly
how well you're doing with
your capacity reservations.
And when I say capacity reservations,
I mean, both ODCR and capacity blocks.
And you can see how efficiently
you're actually using those reservations.
And when I say efficiently
using or utilization,
I mean is an instance on or off?
I'm not talking about
like CPU utilization.
You'll also be able to see
kind of the estimated cost
of all of your underutilized
capacity reservations
so that you can go in and see
where are you spending money
that you're not getting the
best bang for your buck.
You'll also be able to see usage
and what percentage of your
usage is actually covered
by a capacity reservation.
And then even Spot.
Normally, I'm gonna just
give a an aside here.
This was one of our test accounts.
So normally, you're gonna see a lot better
than 44% utilization.
You're gonna see a lot better
than one hour of interruption time.
That's just us testing things out.
But you can also see, okay,
where am I getting interrupted
and where am I getting good usage of Spot
so that if I'm not getting
the runtimes that I want
I can go add more flexibility.
We'll also give you usage metrics.
And you can break out
those usage metrics by vCPU
in vCPU hours, by
instances, instance hours,
and even estimated cost.
You'll be able to see,
okay, what percentage
of your on-demand usage is covered
by a capacity reservation,
what percentage is not covered
and then what's also running on Spot.
And then you can see kind of
the usage trends across time
to see how things are are changing.
You'll also be able to see
kind of deep dive into reservation metrics
and see what's used and not used.
And then we'll have this
unused capacity section,
which basically gives you
your top instance type
and AZ kind of cross sections
where you have the most
unused capacity reservations.
And then finally, you'll be
able to actually track out Spot.
So let's look at what it
looks like to deep dive
into one of these things.
So say I wanna, you know,
I have some reservations
that I'm not using
as efficiently as possible
as I'm looking across
all of my organization,
I can click into reservations
and kind of see some of the same things.
So we see the date filter,
we see new things like dimension
filter and aggregations.
The aggregations is where all
of your data is going to lie.
And right now, like I said,
we start at the top and
then let you dive deeper.
And we'll go into that in one second here.
But you also will see different statistics
about your capacity
reservations and then trends.
So say now I have, you know,
715 reservations is a lot
for me to kind of think
about or grok in my head.
So if I wanna kind of break
out those reservations,
I could choose something
like instance family
or availability zone.
And then when I do that,
it breaks everything out into,
now I have my instance family
and availability zone there
so I can see exactly,
okay, I have four reservations
of m5 in use1-az1,
and now it's a lot easier
for me to kind of go and dive
into each one of those reservations.
You can also filter the reservation.
So if I only wanna look at m5,
I could click that little plus button,
or I could dive even deeper
into the reservations
and kind of apply those filters and see,
okay, what are statistics?
It's about just that line item?
See different trends about
what's being used or not used.
And then even dive into
specific reservation IDs.
And if I wanted to, I could even,
I'm not gonna subject you to that,
but you could even click into
the individual reservation IDs
and actually make changes
to those reservations.
Now, there's a few other features
that I just wanted to point out
because I know we're
running short on time.
One is usage.
So the usage tab works very similarly
to the reservations tab
where you would be able to see,
okay, your total usage trends,
what's covered by a reservation,
what's not covered by a reservation,
and even your spot usage.
And you would, same thing,
you could break it out
by instance family, AZ,
count ID, whatever you'd like.
Then you would also have the Spot,
and this is where you
can kind of dive into
some of your runtime
metrics so you can find out,
okay, where do I need
to spend some more time
making my Spot fleets more flexible
so that I can get better runtime?
And then if you wanted to,
so this is available through
the dashboard, through APIs.
Or if you wanna set up a data export,
which is basically just an
hourly dump of all of your data,
you can set it up to go
into your an S3 bucket,
which is the only thing that
you would ever have to pay for
with Capacity Manager, was
the storage cost for S3.
But you can have data
export set up to every hour,
just give you all of your data
and then you can use
something like Athena,
AWS Athena or AWS Glue
to do transformations
on that if you'd like.
So kind of wrapping it all together,
Capacity Manager is a fantastic way
for you to take all of
the different things
that we've talked about today
and wrap 'em up into a single bow
so that you can make sure
that your organization
is using everything as
efficiently and effectively
as you possibly can.
You can either set it
up as an account level,
which would just mean all
your data in a single account,
or if you have access to the payer account
or a delegated admin of the payer account,
you can set it up at the org level.
And so that would be kind
of the call to action today.
It's completely free to go
and set up Capacity Manager
within your accounts,
within your organization
because it's gonna give
you a much better view
of what's going on without
having to kind of go to all the,
you know, 10 different
tools to figure it out.
So just to kind of wrap
everything up here,
some of the key takeaways
that we wanna make sure
that we highlight on,
one is, you know, EC2 has a
bunch of different usage models,
not one, there's no silver
bullet or singular usage model
that's gonna work best for everybody.
Oftentimes we see most
organizations use all
of the different usage models
because they have different workloads
that they need to optimize.
And so it's gonna be a
balance between the two
or between all of them.
And finding that balance
is incredibly important.
Second thing is,
if you want to kind of continue
to tune things like cost
and availability, you
can add savings plans,
which if you're willing to
commit for that one-year
or three-year term, you
can get large discounts
on your on-demand usage.
Or if you add flexibility to workload,
you can improve your
capacity availability.
And three, if you wanna manage
your EC2 instances at scale
or your EC2 capacity at
scale, use Capacity Manager.
It's really easy.
And so wanna say thank you so much.
Sorry for all the technical difficulties,
but really appreciate your time.
If you wanna connect
with Carlos or myself,
here's our LinkedIn profiles.
Thank you very much.
- [Carlos] Thanks, everyone.
(audience applauding)